[Musique]
c'est l'info football du moment la star
du fc barcelone lionel messi libre de
tout contrat en fin de saison aurait des
envies d'ailleurs et pourquoi pas de
paris saint germain comme le laissent
entendre certaines informations à lionel
messi et toute sa famille prennent des
cours de français en effet c'est pas
très étonnant que le président du club
nasser el khalil fille soit très actif
sur le dossier surtout après s'être vu
proposer le deal du siècle par cyril
hanouna et si messi des au psg je prends
8k bonnement pour des téléspectateurs et
moi d'accord 8 abonnement qui ne seront
pas trop pour payer la prime à la
signature ainsi que le salaire annuel
mirobolant de la star estimé à près de
131 millions d'euros tout au fond du et
pour ceux qui ne se rendrait pas bien
compte c'est une somme qui permettrait
entre autres à benjamin castaldi de
divorcer encore dix-huit fois alors
messi va-t-il rejoindre son ami neymar
au paris saint germain où donne tous les
détails d'un transfert qui pourrait être
historique
les chéris alors on a des infos sur le
transfert de messi je sais que ça
intéresse tout le monde un directionnel
messi au paris saint germain
j'ai gardé très bonne nouvelle c'est que
c'est faisable le psg est vraiment sur
la liste pour engager lui à une missile
alors le salaire de mai 631 millions
c'est tout confondu le salaire de mai 6
et 50 millions bruts par saison ce sera
un contrat de trois ans ou une maman
donc il faut savoir à quel âge déjà v6
là il a 33 donc 33 ouais mais neymar
neymar 7,37 millions d'euros bruts
emma pc 22 millions donc mais si c'est
beaucoup plus cher la mauvaise nouvelle
c'est que si messi vient ça veut dire
que quelqu'un que vous adorez 120 ce
sera m bape et je sais que cela est en
liberté
il est en ce moment valorisée à 150
millions parce que son prix a baissé en
raison du contexte sanitaire c'est ça
donc ils vendraient mba paix qui
hésitent acquis au real madrid et pour
messi ils sont en concurrence avec
manchester city où il retrouverait
guardiola son entraîneur mais messi est
très chaud parce qu'un entraîneur
argentin ya dix mariages failli échouer
nema il est très chauds lait bio c'est
faisable mais sans mba pays
mais vous savez que le psg extrêmement
confidentielles d'habitude en termes de
communication est la leur stratégie
c'est d'assumer clairement qu'ils
veulent mais c'est donc moi j'ai appelé
le psg ont dit oui on veut mais si tu
n'avais plus le stand alfa naissance et
donc ça c'est la première fois et la
deuxième un beau soir je suis dressé un
petit
et la deuxième info c'est qu'un chasseur
de maison qui est spécialisé dans les
joueurs de foot qui est le mec qui a
trouvé la maison de neymar à bougival en
banlieue parisienne cherche actuellement
une maison pour messi oris maryse yens
voilà qui me contacter si j'ai pas fait
le psg mais je partage ma vie avec avec
le meilleur journaliste de foot de
france voire d'europe dont l'eau qu'on
aurait la race non en fait le problème
de messi egypte la réflexion n'est pas
bonne c'est qu'en fait le barça ne veut
plus de lui
ouais et donc il ya qu un club qui peut
le payer aujourd'hui même si c'est moins
que ce qu'il a l'habitude d'avoir
c'est le psg donc aucun doute sur le
fait qu'il viendra au psg et la deuxième
chose et c'est une fake news personnes
de sa famille il est en train
d'apprendre le français
ça fait très longtemps qu'il est au
barça au barça à barcelone il apprend
pas que le catalan pour autant donc en
fait saint cyr à vrai que c'est une
fille ou l'accord va très bien merci
et donc ils cherchent une maison ça
c'est une vraie offensive ils cherchent
une maison va écouter si vous avez un
petit studio accueillir merci bien
entendu